good morning councilors
and guests
welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee I'm councilor John
Hinton and I'm chairing the meeting
today
my first remind you of some domestic
Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use and that you
do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones and
laptops are on silent
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern gov app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council member the council members
of the public and the Press May record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and the Press
are not lawfully excluded
I would just add at this point that I
will be taking items 13 to 16. that's
the various work plans after item nine
and we'll be postponing item 11 to the
end of the proceedings so that when we
go into confidential session that will
be the last item on the on the
proceedings
in attendance today we have dye Robinson
interim director of communities and
well-being
Sally longmate CEO of Suffolk
Association of local councils
Jan Robinson corporate manager of Law
and governance and Alicia Norman lead
officer for overview and scrutiny
and councilor Mary McLaren who is the
BDC Cabinet member for communities
can I move to the agenda please
thank you chair we have apology
and we have councilor Davey substituting
for councilor Wellington
no right to receive Declarations of
pecuni other registerable or non-regis
registerable interests by members
none none good
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
none received you
to confirm the minutes of the joint
meeting held on the 21st of November
2022.
first of all are there any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
councilor Barrett thank you um chair um
on the 21st November I believe that was
the meeting we spoke about the cab
um
another presentation
um I would like to ask for an amendment
because I think there's no mention my
comments about the
Community Supermarket
apologies if that's not the right term
for it but um it's it's along those
lines I had to express some concerns
about viability cost
as it assumes people will have the means
and the time to travel to a central
facility
um so I I'd hope that that would be
reflected in the minutes
thank you chair yeah
um
well I can I can remember it being
discussed so certainly I would be in
favor of having that
Edition put into the minutes
any other comments on the minutes
could I have a proposal for the minutes
then please with the addition of the
item on concerning Community
supermarkets or whatever they're called
councilman
a second uh councilor Grandin
the governance officer will conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
thank you chair that is eight votes for
says unanimous
the minutes of the joint meeting on the
21st of November have been confirmed
with the amendment that has been
proposed
now then forbaber members only to
confirm the minutes of the baber meeting
held on the 21st of November
Council Osborne
um thank you Mr chairman uh correction
to the minutes on the 21st with the
um
particular it was that that councilor
Jan Osborne was in attendance in the
afternoon and it's not on that on the
on the actual minutes so also she did
answer several questions that are not
limited either
so the minute
the minute of atom um they are just to
capture the thread obviously we do
stream live and all of the whole meeting
is recorded and it's able to be repeat
viewed so um we can certainly add cancer
Jan Osborne to to the um to the minutes
as the portfolio in attendance portfolio
holder in attendance but we couldn't
list every single question and answer
that everybody makes in ons because we'd
you know it's they're not verbatim
minutes is to give you a flavor so
um unless there's a particular point
that cancer Oswald would like
added we would just leave it that she
uh we can add that she answered a
um a number of questions on on the issue
and um you know refer captains back to
the live stream for um a full record of
the meeting
yeah
um perhaps um Jan you could speak to her
about that I will yeah I'll take it out
but we can certainly add in that she
answered questions
um on the issues yeah I think the main
thing was it she did attend the
afternoon it was in the afternoon and
she did attend yeah so we can add that
in I think and I'll you know generally
said that she answered questions
um on on the issue there was hro so she
would have had to come in on certain
occasions yeah so yes we that in as a
general but without getting into this
each
video thank you
I could have a propose if there are no
more
comments on those minutes cover proposal
from the baby members councilor Barrett
seconder please
they'll be going to Second them
yes oh definitely
cancer Osborne and so those submit those
are the baber minutes from the meeting
in the afternoon of the 21st
with the addition of the presence of
councilor Osborne and
any particular points that she would
like including in the minutes in terms
of the questions she asked
all those in favor do you want no
electronic vote sorry electronic vote
again
thank you chair um is now in progress
or baber counselors only
I left my brick at home
foreign
that is four votes four and one
abstentions that is carried
and next
to confirm the minutes of the mid-suffet
meeting held on the 22nd of November
2022 and these are from mid-suffolk
Members Only
are there any points of accuracy
concerning the minutes
no
I'm gonna have a proposal please
cancel customers
when I moved to the electronic boat
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress and this is formid Suffolk
councilors only
thank you chair that is two votes for
and what abstention so that's character
thank you members and move on then to
questions by the public
and received you
questions by councilors none received
move on to item nine the review of the
Suffolk Association of
oh we're gonna do the S Salk first
foreign
Association of local councils at the
Salk
I'd like to invite the cabinet member
for communities to introduce a report to
the committee
well I am doubly happy because I was the
one that actually requested this screw
to the item about two years ago so I'm
delighted to be here uh to support Sully
Longway who is the Chief Executive
Officer of Salk I think Salk is an
important part of our
um
workers board members and we can work
together with Salk to improve the
effectiveness of Parish and town
councils so I'm delighted for Sally to
present the report to you thank you
chair
okay yes good morning I think I've got a
PowerPoint present
that hopefully will be coming up shortly
that's great thank you and I just want
to double check that I can use the
technology correctly so thank you very
much for this opportunity to talk to you
this morning about what Salk is all
about the Suffolk Association of local
councils we've been going for a number
of years I've been in post for just over
four years and obviously been through
covid for half of those but we've been
around since about 1950 something we're
part of a network of 43 County
associations across the UK supporting 10
000 Talent Parish councils so quite a
significant number uh quite uh you know
once you start to put some money against
that as well it's quite quite an amount
of money
um we are membership based so
effectively parish councils and this was
the origins of the
of how it worked way back councils
wanted somewhere to go somewhere to
support them to train them to keep them
what we've known as a head of the curve
so they put their money in in the middle
of the table and set up a not-for-profit
organization which has been replicated
across the UK so each County Association
is independent we are affiliated or we
are linked to the National Association
of local councils
and they do quite a lot of lobbying for
us nationally and it's an important
Network
um so our operating model is that we are
member driven so they direct what we do
um we are have got very good reputation
for having good sector knowledge
um a good example of that is our
advisory Services which is one of our
most valued services so we are at the
end of a phone for our members
um sometimes an hour before the meeting
sometimes immediately after a meeting
and Clarks and counselors chairs and
clerks have the direct line to us we
don't
um
ordinarily speak directly to councilors
the chair at sometimes the vice chair if
they're authorized and the clerk have
the key to the door and we reassure them
we help them we direct them we send them
information we set things up if we need
to and look at other ways that we can
support and it's hugely valued
we receive on average
around
100 or so technical inquiries quite
detailed technical inquiries a month but
a lot more during the day operational
inquiries the majority of which we deal
with as a team but we do have a suite of
experts on
um
and governance on VAT on Finance on
legal we sometimes use an out legal who
do legal topic notes for the sector we
have someone on Village halls and we
obviously have good working
relationships with a monitoring officer
and with other officers throughout the
network and so if we can't answer it
then we know someone hopefully who will
be able to so that's a good
um uh sort of overview of our knowledge
our services are very focused to the
town and Parish Council sector because
that's what our members want us to do so
in addition to the advisory Services we
ought to offer training and development
sometimes we try and do things for free
I do as much for free so once they've
paid their subs and the added value is
as broad as we can make it and certainly
under my time I have expanded that
significantly because what was important
to me is I don't want Town marriage
councils to be a South because we always
have been so it's on the agenda item in
you know in October when they're looking
at budgets we've always we've always had
sound we can't do without them not sure
what we use them for but we'll pay it
anyway that's not really the type of
service that I was in
we want to be a partner by their side
and a trusted support organization
shaped by them
so in addition to additional training we
do forums which have expanded hugely
during covid and we've maintained them
so we've had to really think about smart
working to to keep that going so we have
climate forums we have networks for
chairs and mares we have week monthly
networks for Clarks we have our
quarterly area forums which is based on
District they're not we've got about 20
of our members attend them and maybe a
little less
um and it's always been an issue getting
councilors to come to our area forums so
we are reviewing them they were being
reviewed when I started four and a bit
years ago so this is not a new issue and
I have um explored what the operating
models are across the UK and the board
will be looking at that in the new year
for our area forums we've got a number
of things that we've tried out we've
done topic based ones with the police
and Prime commissioner we have speakers
such as transport East that came to the
East Suffolk ones more recently and we
have broadcast that out to members
across the network
hoping that we will do some more with
other stakeholders West Suffolk we do
joint liaison with them with that local
Authority and we regularly get you know
between 50 and 80 attendees to that
session because it's a party worth going
to
and that's really what we're trying to
lessons look get lessons learned from
that
in terms of development we have invested
or the board have invested in a new case
management system which will allow us to
be much more with smarter working so our
members have a portal it's a work room
it will be rolled out to councilors
either after elections or before we're
not too sure yet because um it's a busy
start to 2023 for us
that is tools of the trade it gives them
Hands-On information around legal topic
notes
it gives them the model Council which is
a new online resource that we've
developed that takes all the sector
information that's fragmented and puts
it into a dynamic online tool that they
can use however with all of these great
Innovative things that we've introduced
so that we're developing what we do and
how we do it we remain available at the
end of the phone what our members don't
want is a system where it's a
a reporting tool so to speak we do not
want to become faceless that is not the
sector that we represent we represent
outside your front door and we need to
be at the side of a clerk or a chair
um which to be honest is quite uh you
know they're on the coal face and it's
sometimes can be quite a challenging and
for those single employees quite a
lonely place so we are very focused on
being available at all times
so that's that in terms of our operating
model we have a constitution we have a
business plan which I'm going on to now
and we have three very plain objectives
there which you can see up on the screen
and within our annual review our report
which we do in July our AGM we go over
our financial summary we review all of
our activities we present our structure
and our governance and we look forward
so we don't just look back at that
meeting so I would if you want to know
more about South in a in a nutshell have
a look at our annual report because
that's got um it's a really really good
document and it shows you
um all that we do and a little bit more
because it looks ahead
um and it's it's yeah I think it's it's
a it's a really good way of
understanding our roles and
responsibility so we've said very
briefly about what we provide webinars
and podcasts podcasts is fairly new I'm
just waiting for some new equipment to
arrive in what is our now smaller
offices so we've um we've looked at our
running costs we've looked at how we
were operating during covid we've kept
the best bits as our as part of our
moving out of covid plans and we're
saving our members money which we're
reinvesting as you would expect
we also have e-bulletins that go to
Clarks this is a really important point
in terms of collaboration if you take
anything away take this away in that
Clarks have information falling from the
ceilings at them quite often it's
duplicated it was a lesson learned from
covid we were given tasks for example as
part of a network to provide information
or pass information on but we were
finding that cat district county and
other organizations were doing the same
we'd all been asked to do the same and
so the risk there is the client will see
something and probably
um think well I've seen it here here and
here and there might be a nugget of
information in your comms that they miss
because it was accompanied by something
they'd seen before so my aspiration is
that we work collaboratively as a
network that we get information that's
accurate and timely but we don't send it
20 times which when you're a clerk only
working a few hours away week it is a
real challenge
a challenge for us too is that
information being passed on mainly
because you know how can you such as a
small amount of hours pass information
on and that's why our
membership portal will be so important
to councilors because it means that
they've got things at their fingertips
and look back at newsletters look at
some of the headlines look at info link
which we have on there
promotion of the cost of living support
for example so e bulletins on a Monday
to class our technical they're the
things that they need to think about and
they need to be aware of and they're
ahead of the curve Tuesdays I also get
Tuesdays and Wednesdays mixed up but one
is training and development so looking
at what events we've got coming up and
Wednesdays are vacancies because we do
promote vacancies as well the other
additional Services which I forgot to
mention were that we provide Payroll
Services to councils which is very much
valued we've got it's grope grows every
year I think we're 140 150 Council
councils that we do it for at the moment
and we provide a much valued service it
gives them resilience and consistency
and it just takes a job away from the
clock and we do it as cheaply as we
possibly can and we also do an internal
audit Service as well
which is you know during the normal
season and again we have over a hundred
councils that use that service and we
have quite a strict operating
procedure for that and we use external
actually
working clerks to run that service and
we feed that back into the results of
the audit with feedback into well where
are the gaps where are we seeing the
trends what can we do to improve that
guidance and templates is on the
um on the portal and finally in terms of
lobbying and representation well I've
got a place on a number of
um
groups within Suffolk and nationally so
I'm on the national Improvement and
development board and I'm also a Silka
the certificate and local Council award
scheme
um sorry certificate in local Council
Administration silke I'm an accredited
trainer for that and that's
developing Clarks with a qualification
and that comes through the Improvement
and development board there's also a
quality scheme called the local Council
award scheme as well
so I work nationally on that an
improvement as well as Improvement for
County officers like myself so we also
need quite a lot of support because of
the ever-changing
coal face actually of the public sector
which is where we're all working I also
meet with MPS regularly we have three
that are members of our in of our
organization as vice presidents and we
compare our notes every so often what's
in your inbox what a council saying to
you what are the challenges what are now
nationally lobbying about at the moment
it is around remote meetings which has
been on the agenda for a long long time
also internet banking or banking per se
for councils it's really challenging
when there's changes to signatories
there's no really good service out there
so there's just a couple of examples of
lobbying that we're doing and
representation and at the networks that
I'm at in Suffolk I do rep and I'm known
as we need South in the room for Town
and Parish councils massive challenge
for me I don't have enough hours in the
day to go at what is an ever increasing
list of meetings and I'm very open and
honest about that if I go to a meeting
and it's an hour or two long and all
we're being asked is to Cascade
information the smarter way would have
been just to ask us to Cascade
information if you want us as a a
working group and you want to listen to
councils about their challenges
different kettle of fish we can enable
that but it is that I find that the most
challenging and I'm very open about that
well
uh yeah so sector knowledge development
so I've talked about the model Council
which is our new online resource that
we're developing we were hoping that
would be a national resource it has
but we are going it alone because uh
we're you know we've had to wait quite a
long time for anything to get moving so
the board said just do it so we're
working very hard on that cool training
with counselors Clarks rfos chairs and
the whole Council
cover core training for councilors and
it's never been more successful so we're
regularly two three four evenings a week
sometimes running counselor training
hundreds of sessions for counselors the
things that we've got coming up in the
new year is a really good collaborative
piece again for you to take away which
is around briefings for count for clerks
for elections so we did that in the past
and I wasn't really very much involved
in it because it was four years ago so
it kind of just happened this year we've
been directly as we did before but a bit
more focused with election teams in your
respective authorities so it means that
it's something worth the cat clerk going
to we'll record it we'll put it within
our model Council we've developed our
model Council articles on elections and
co-option and so we're piecing it all
together it means that the clerk can go
to one briefing session they've got a
Clark account a trainer from South going
over the operational stuff and they've
got an election officer going over the
authorities process and I think that is
a really good joining of our knowledge
and information so that it's valuable we
also did the same for the code of
conduct with monitoring officers so
authorities kindly paid for one of the
authors of the LGA councilor code of
conduct to run three sessions I think it
was
um sessions which we recorded one of
which we've embedded into the model
Council and we've actually bookmarked it
because it was a long two-hour session
um on the LGA code of conduct in an
evening
um and um so we've bookmarked it it's on
YouTube but it's not listed and it
allows new counselors which we'll be
using in the new year to actually fast
forward to some examples myself and my
advice manager are also going to do a
dropping session now the LGA code of
conduct is sort of settled and we're
going to do some fun sessions with
Clarks who are like you have officers
here you know in a meeting and then
issue comes up and they've got to think
on their feet it is a new code of
conduct they've moved away from the
Suffolk One how can we help the clerks
work their way through it with some
practical examples that's just something
we'll do as part of the network
other examples of training are project
management training which I'm I have
done and I'm going to redo in the new
year for Clarks that are looking to
expand because project management can go
from small events to large events and
it's a skill that they should have in
their training and development program
if they're interested we've also done
comms and marketing how to engage youth
how
some things around speeding but they've
been they've been free events with the
police and crime commissioner
anti-social Behavior we've done with
them so there's lots that we're doing
um and I think probably the the fastest
growing one is our climate Forum so that
is sector driven so councilors and Clark
said could we have a climate Forum could
we all sit in a room and talk about our
plans what you're doing learn from each
other the core of what South does and
um could now Salk enable that and we
have and actually we are now working
with the collaborators working work
stream for greenish County and we're
seen as a very very proactive partner
um and we're at a you know we're at
Junction parishes are at a junction with
climate matters
um you know what more can they do and
interested in what district councils are
doing so back at you in that do they
understand your plans would District
come and talk to our group would they
help us so we join it up otherwise
they'll read about it on social media as
will I or within the paper and see what
you're doing is think well actually
that's a shame because we were having
that discussion only two weeks ago so
um there's a um a kind of an another
example of developing the sector
knowledge
you can find out more about south on our
website it's a new website it was the
last thing for us to do in terms of our
developing new ways of working as well
as moving offices and our new systems
um it is designed to Showcase what we do
and how we do it you can sign up to our
local councilor magazine through that
and you can view the current one
um we wanted to do that we didn't really
have systems to do it very well we were
just using Outlook you know we don't
have it support you know in terms of an
in-house team we have to figure it out
for ourselves so it took us a little
while to do the design and get it right
but the website is a showcase about what
South does what councils do what Clarks
do what projects we're involved in we're
after a target audience of District
councilors like yourself because we'd
like you to know more about what we do
we know that monitoring officers will
Advocate and other officers will say are
you members of South
and so that so that councils are sort of
engaged in the support that we do
but it showcases our involvement in the
climate Forum so you can look at that
you can look at the recordings of those
sessions and the resources we offer you
can look at the Queen's green canopy
which we were very much involved in for
Suffolk which was tree planting you can
find out about
service because it's all free on there
to have a look at it really shouts about
what South does we don't have a comms
and marketing officer we are at the coal
phase because we're supporting the coal
face of the public sector and that's
where our time goes if our members
wanted to invest in a comms and
marketing person then you know maybe
things would be a bit different but our
service is to our members if you want to
know more about our services our our
website and our front window uh you know
that's that's where we advertise and
hopefully we can do a little bit more on
social media and hopefully if you signed
up to the local counselor you would see
some more around that and finally we
must develop the sector so we want to
attract more diverse people and help
councils recruit so our website is
designed to do that as well it's on its
Journey it's not perfect but we hope
we'll expand it so we'd like podcasts
from chairs Mayors Clarks
hoping to work with the Suffolk branch
of the Society of local Council clerks
on developing Pathways for Clarks
developing Pathways for councilors we
have got that on our website at the
moment but we want to expand it more so
I'm a new councilor what do I need to
know I have a four-year term
um you know what training should I go on
how do I keep up to date
so that's a very very quick run through
I don't know how long I've taken I
didn't have my
but I hope that is useful
thank you very much indeed um Charlie
it's been both informative having been
uh both the parish councilor as well as
a district councilor for quite a number
of years now uh
it's always interesting to hear what is
new within Salk because it is like most
councils constantly evolving and
councils have to of all levels have to
keep up to date with things
any questions for Sally
Davis
uh so I I see that you uh have liaison
meetings with West Suffolk District
Council
are there any formal links with with
ignorance obviously
and if not
would it be helpful to have some formal
links
it's emerging for baber mid-suffolk
kind of reach down
and we did have some officers come to
our most recent area forums which we
recorded that segment to actually
introduce the new locality framework the
locality team that you've got and that
would allow that parishes to understand
that little bit more and the help and
what's been developed so that was really
encouraging
um it I think because each district
operates slightly differently we hope
would like to have a model that would
work I can explain to you that in West
Suffolk we have joint Parish liaison so
the leader of council and I opened them
and we we agree some topics what's
slightly missing from that that we've
learned is that whilst we get the
numbers there and it's a party worth
going to which is great big tick it the
council lose their voice a little bit
they're talked at rather than with and
working with them
um and that's not necessarily
um what our members want you know this
is a network for them to say this is
this is our concern at the moment or
this is a great piece of work that we've
done we want to tell you about it and
then for the sector to say oh I'm going
to have a look at that we're going to
take that and we're going to replicate
it instead of Reinventing the wheel so
it I think it needs to be a hybrid of
that um
look at that with with West Suffolk I've
started to talk to them about that it
could be we have one jointly liaison per
annum and we have our own South Forum
but the whole thing is in the Melting
Pot for the board to look at
strategically
um in East Suffolk we they have a they
don't have liaison meetings we they fund
a part of a post in South they they have
their Community Partnership
um framework you know model and we as
part of the pilot are right from the day
one when I arrived at South you Suffolk
wanted to speak to me and I was involved
in that and they told me their plans
which was very encouraging and
Innovative and we also wanted to bring
the tears together to avoid that
duplication to enable councils so they
fund a four-hour week post and that is
that bridge between a bit like the
localities bit but we work with the
community teams as well so when I will
see what comes out with baber and Miss
Suffolk it will be the shape that you
want it to be if you're interested
thank you um if I could take this
opportunity to um thank Sally and Salk
for everything they do as some
I was um chairman of summersham Parish
Council and twice
Sal came in and helped the completely
essentially with um issues in there one
was one was the um
the one was a sort of management issue
but the second one was the um sadly the
clerk died suddenly and that that clerk
was um the clerk of seven or eight
um parish councils and um Salk
immediately stepped in and they had a
person
um that we could speak to at any time to
discuss things and they they would
completely essential in getting through
that
um and very sensitive as well with the
situation because it was a it was a very
sad experience but um
the question that I'd like to ask is um
with them the training courses you run
for counselors and clerks
um covert aside
what um how do you see the how are they
sort of trending with them take up
um do they for instance do they get do
you get more people on there or or less
as time goes on and the other thing I
wanted to talk about is um
it's I don't know if any part of those I
have been on the council training course
but a very long time ago but I don't
know if um we um
discuss on those the boundaries of what
a Clark
is expected to do and what's um Beyond
there and you know their job description
because I do sometimes find that Parish
councilors ask a huge amount to their
Clerk and sometimes they're doing things
that aren't necessarily
um fair to expect a clerk to do so yeah
those those two questions and um yeah a
lot of my other questions
um have been explained in the
presentation which I think is some a
good ever for self that you've um you've
covered every single um based on this um
report so well so thank you
thank you for that
um we can't we we can't run enough
training sessions so it may well be that
the training you came to was face to
face and it was a block
um of session or two sessions we now we
broke them up because of covid and going
online and we've retained that
um so they are
um you know their their modules and
they're based on one's roles and
responsibilities and that's in answer to
your second question we are very clear
about the roles and responsibilities of
councilors
yes there is a big ask of Clarks I agree
and we do that we do very much impress
on what what what the council is as a
corporate body as well as them
individually around standards and code
of conduct that they are responsible for
and have duties to perform
and hopefully that is enough we get very
we get very good feedback on that but I
think there's another arch of that which
is employment matters and HR matters
which we do have very much is reactive
and we do look at you say about
management we do see that there are
changes when it comes to management so
have you got your policies and
procedures do you understand your
responsibility as an employer and do you
manage your Clerk and support them be in
their training in their development
um you know in in their role which is
quite often ever expanding so there
should be a review of their job
description there should be regular
one-to-ones Etc and that's something
that we're really starting to push on
there will be some new online resources
that will really focus councils on that
that they can just use instead of them
having to develop them individually so
but we can't put on enough training
without a shadow of a doubt and I think
the challenge for us is to get some more
trainers and make them available
I don't I can't remember the second half
of the question now I do apologize I
think you've covered everything in my um
question it was about the take-up which
you've um explained and um the Clark's
position how that's outlined and um yeah
yeah no I think I've got everything that
I ask for thank you very much okay
okay regularly with the chief exec at
the county here they do give us some
funding which helps us operate which is
massively appreciated because we are
very small we can only do there's so
much we could do but you know we I have
to keep on on on point I can't Mission
creep in terms of what our objectives
are but we are very limited in what we
can do but in terms of the county deal
we are seen as an estate holder in
engagement for that
um and my lobbying represent
representative role is that you know we
need to be very clear about how what
councils can do um and maybe I look
under the Bonnet every day and I can see
that there are challenges for them their
day their day job and again you can find
this on our website their calendar of
business as usual is there for all to
see before the planning applications
come in before they're considering
neighborhood development plans which are
massive pieces of work before there's
any or infrastructure projects which is
another big issue that I'm involved in
to help that sector
handle that because we've got a lot
probably the most in the country in in
the East and again I'm talking to MPS
and you know ministers about that and
also the county where we can expand that
so these are things that you've got a
clerk that has actually fielding and
it's very very challenging and we need
to think about the skills and we need to
think where that line is blurred so it
should be more collaboratively a
approached and the n61 is a really
interesting one because parishes will do
their response and you're all in the
same boat actually when it comes to
nsips but the parishes don't actually
have offices like you do they don't have
lawyers to hand they don't have procure
you don't have professional officers to
hand so how can we enable them to work
smarter and you know represent the
community it's a massive challenge that
and that's a good example of you know
the future things that we need to think
about
councilor Dawson
yes what I was wondering is you were
talking
um it says about protecting the
privilege of members and High
um Quality Specialists support
how does that work say with some of
these uh councils where they've got a
lot of issues with the code of conduct
do you get involved with that or do you
refer that to the councilors association
who sort of have the legal expertise is
that something that you do or is not
really when it comes to stuff we refer
to the monitoring officers when there's
any code of conduct issues and that's
you know
we meet regularly with them if there are
any challenges then you know we share
some of that knowledge and make sure
that we're on the same
um uh point on that what we can do is we
do have so how are you so um Harry aanko
Associates who wrote the council Agoda
conduct we have a service level
agreement with them so if there is a
scenario or a particular thing that a
council or a clerk is not clear on and
they've been told to go away and check
we can always get that expertise in we
can also ask them out legal legal or we
can perhaps speak to the monitoring
officer but we have got very clear lines
that if it is a code of conduct matter
then they must be to the monitoring
officer about a lot of these issues with
the um with the uh
uh you know I'm guessing some things you
know I'm hardly North and a lot of these
issues seem to drag on
um do you have quite a lot of protocols
in place and particularly for disputes
between members
the protocols we have is that we don't
necessarily get involved with the you
know we don't we our hotline it and I
said that earlier it's the counts it's
the Claire Clark and the chair that have
access to our services otherwise there
is a risk that we're getting all the
different stories and that's no good to
anybody if there are councils who are um
and you know having some difficulties we
have on occasion gone in and looked at
how we can help them in partnership with
the monitoring officer so we've looked
at well these are the challenges how
we've gone in and done training whole
Council training so if you're protecting
the the members here with heart support
does that apply just for the business
only really it's we support the council
so our service is not to any one
individual including the clerk so if
anything happens in terms of you know
employment matters with Clark our
support is to the corporate body always
to the corporate body they are the
member
just as a matter of
0.4.3 should we perhaps amend that
because it it just seems to me quite
confusing it says it protects the
Privileges of the members and I wonder
where that's slightly misleading because
this is more about the business not
actually about the members is it really
and that's what I was getting at really
um yeah um yeah yeah I mean yeah I'm
also
more than you know for that to be
clarified if that's if that's yeah if if
that's
um unclear I I mean some of the other
National work that that's going on is
Civility and respect which is a national
project which um my colleagues other
County officer colleagues uh I've been
involved in and will be coming out that
that's our new resources in terms of
employment matters and being a good
employer
um because there's you know there's a
number of things in there about how we
treat each other and there is a pledge
that councils can sign up to for example
frankly only four in Suffolk have done
that so far but hopefully you know some
some podcasts and some more information
that we're that we will be issuing so
you have would take on sort of racial
issues and perhaps hate campaigns then
no no you don't yes so absolutely not no
I just wonder whether that point should
perhaps 0.2 or 4.3
the second bullet point might mean
slightly amending
I think there's a little bit of word
play going on there as as much as
anything else and interests rights
functions and privileges that's not EU
type privileges that's correct but in
fact the privilege of being able to do
the job as a parish counselor as much as
anything else
um I think if we're if we're talking
about something to do with
hate campaigns or race or anything like
that so it's not really protect it's
protecting the business side of all this
but not actually members
effectively
which is fair enough I mean that's
that's not their line of business but it
just
quite that's not quite what it says
there is it really councilman you wanted
to say
thank you
um only on that point if
if
um salt was formed in 1950
to do those functions depends whether we
put those words together or sulk and put
those words together
um you know if that's what they were
formed in 1950 to do then we we can't
really personally hear in this Council
change their
their
um
what they're intended to do we can maybe
just suggest that they look at that line
themselves and and
um but it's not really for us to to
change
what the remit is
awesome it depends who wrote These
bullet points whether that was us
interpreting as a council or whether
that we whether that's sulks
um own words and their own remit
in terms of who wrote the report that
report came from die Robinson in
communities so um Sally
no one from South wrote the report
what we'll do is we'll take away from
that and make sure that within our
literature and I'm pretty sure it is
fairly clear that we support the
corporate body and if they're and I will
I will ask the team do they think that
there is you know does this maybe
detract from that and have we got it
clearer elsewhere and I'll certainly
take that away but these are objectives
that you know that have been embedded I
honestly I can't off the top of my head
I'd have to look at the two to make sure
that they do match
um because this report was was um by die
Robinson and um I will double check that
but I can I'll take that away for sure
but it is something that's within our
constitution
um and for South sorry thank you it's
just it's helpful because you know if we
need to refer things on maybe we
shouldn't be referring them on to you
because that's you know probably not
really your area of expertise
I think it's probably appropriate that
the form of wording is looked at
um and perhaps modified slightly to make
it clearer
and and more
functional
any other any other questions
counselor McLaren did you why should you
say something thank you chair which
would address the questions to you or to
Sally
to Sally
Sally thank you for that presentation uh
you've worked really hard over the last
hmm
yes I think to
improve the communication between
sulk and its members and board members
when I've got two questions that are
really
um
are a common problem I think with Parish
councils especially those that are not
very adequately set up so
in terms of training we know how
important that is for councilors and the
clerk what if the parish doesn't have
the money
uh sufficient funds to actually fund the
training and perhaps linked to the hat
with your online training as that
altered the cost of the training by
going online
okay so the cost of the training online
hasn't hasn't um changed in fact it's
more
flexible so previously you had to sign
up to
X number of sessions when we did it face
to face
um you know on reflection now it was
probably a bit restrictive in that the
majority were during the day we did do
some weekends one and the odd evening
one
um and
um you had to sign up as a hundred and
something pounds for those sessions we
broke it down into modules that allows
and counselors do do this they're mostly
in the evening because our trainers can
can only can only do it then
um so that I think that has provided
quite a lot of flexibility if you can't
come we can record it and they can watch
it afterwards and they could just use it
and we always promote it like this if
you do the whole lot and actually you
need to
um
skill up on roles and responsibilities
or Finance module then you could just
drill into that for 26 pounds I mean
that's what we're talking about 26
pounds for a session per module
sometimes we do Whole Council training
if it's the whole thing if you haven't
got sufficient funds and the example
I've got of that whether it's in
it might have been in baby Midsouth it
was a new clerk been a clerk before came
back on board very small Council needed
to get up to speed came to the area
forums lots of challenges really needed
to pick things up
um and we obviously said well you need
to go on training and immediately we
haven't got the money for that so the
council weren't necessarily looking at
in their calendar what what are we what
are we going to achieve this year
they're due to-do list maybe their
business plan because I want to do it
fancy but basic to-do list when they're
setting the budget what do we want to do
review have we got the capacity have we
got the skills Gap do we need to do some
so these are the logical things that we
encourage councils to look at
um so they obviously weren't doing any
of the above so we would work directly
with the clock as much as we can so we
so looking at now we can use the model
Council before that it was read this
look at that read that legal topic note
I mean you know they're gonna they're
gonna Keel over aren't they when you
send all that stuff so the model council
is much more interactive
um so that's kind of what we did the
model council is another example of
added value so yes we've got smaller
offices
yes we've invested Capital with no extra
help from anyone
um you know just our County
Grant and the income that we make and we
are not for profit so we turn nothing at
the end of the you know true to form
um that allows us to do things and I
really have done things differently I
really have shaken things up and I think
it's been valued so there isn't extra
cost to that so I think looking at the
model Council and looking at in a very
simple form that myself and my advice
manager have written and their questions
and the next thing we're going to do
because we've got our systems now is
we're going to add frequently asked
questions so that if someone else has
asked it you can have the benefit of
that so that's where we would direct to
Clark we'd also say come to our come to
our clock networking so that's included
in your membership and they might
network with a neighboring clerk then
meet up for coffee help them with that
so that's as much as we can do but that
Clark had nothing had no money for
training and development so that's the
that's the key thing to help her help
the council move to that
and we you know we could even go to
their meeting and explain to them you
know look at developing but if if not
then yes you know we're there and that
you know we we've got 375 members we've
got the you know the a number of large
councils we've got a glut of the medium
ones and then smaller ones and we have
to manage and our board is very
passionate about this don't go chasing
the fancy stuff for all these up here
you've got to think about these that are
give me a break I can't look at that
I've got this to do and I've only got
this amount of hours so how do we help
them so we're very tuned into that
Jack can I just ask a second question
thank you
um
if a parish council is struggling uh and
some of them are
to survive
is it
better for them to become a parish
meeting only is that in their best
interest rather than try and
you know comply with the regulation and
all the requirements of a parish council
I don't think I can answer that all I
can say I think we did have that
question and I think our advice managers
said to the parish that you know there's
just been a community governance review
that's the opportunity so the network
around that the information around that
now did that go through did that go fall
through the crack
was the comms around that and in fact
the officer at baber Midsouth I engage
with and said we need to explain this
because a member of our board said to
baber mid-suffolk
councils don't know what this is all
about are you working with salcomit and
we did work on it and tried to explain
it a little bit more that's the
opportunity for parishes to think are we
the right model do we need to look at
whatever but I can't answer the question
whether should they be that if they're
not that I I can't answer that I think
that would be
probably monitoring officers not really
thank you
thank you Chen
um it's been a very good presentation
thank you
um
you've spoken a lot about how you help
um parish and town councils
um a lot of the information that you
just summoned is information from
the larger councils the district and
County Council and so on
um do you get is there anything if you
could make with wave of magic one that
you
us as District councils that would make
your life better or that you'd like to
see work better
um are you getting enough from us to
help the town and Parish councils or is
it all wonderful
um I I aspire to have the tiers of local
government work together
so if there is a key message or we're
doing something on topic that we do it
you know as as one single thing so we
think about
and it could be as simple as the
community's teams or your localities
team doing this could you help us Focus
could you help us get that message out
to councils about it and we would do
that we do that a lot
um
I I yeah it's very difficult isn't it to
work in partnership in collaboratively
um and it's very challenging when you're
doing something and you see something
pop up somewhere else and think what a
shame that could have been really good
if we'd have done it together
I think balance with that is our
challenge that we represent town and
parishes so we must work where we work
smarter together that's what I would ask
for to work smarter and have that
thought process but our challenge Is We
I worry that you know we don't have the
resources to do as much as that we can't
be at every table because it's me at
every table and that's not feasible so
we're not really kitted out to do it but
the best we can do is to Cascade the
information on your behalf
um
so why would you know I think what is
potentially beginning to grow is this
model as working in Partnership so we
have that
um arena for counselors to network
together in their sector
um but also for there to be a party
worth going to maybe as a an information
session and that's understand mutually
what we're doing
but that is back to communication and
it's really really tough
um so I haven't got and I I said I'm
afraid I haven't got an ideal answer for
that
um at all but what don't make the
mistake that if we work collaboratively
about talking to counselors
them retaining their role and also to be
respectful that their time is voluntary
and if anything does come down and I do
make these representations voluntary
time is just as precious as pay time
it needs to be clear about what remits
are and what expectations are
um
and it and and it you know it it it
applies equally to the agencies in the
county as well as it does the districts
so if I see something that someone's
doing over there for example Community
Action software could do in a survey on
what are the barriers for climate change
in your community as a voluntary sector
and our Forum would like that for uh for
our sector so I'm going to just use that
and push it out I'm not going to do my
own survey why would I as long as we can
segment the information and say for the
drill down for the parish and I wish I
was resourced so I could do some of that
stuff and do that analysis but we're not
so I I can't
any other questions
fine thank you very much indeed for your
your input
this report is for noting
rather than anything unless you have any
recommendations that you would like to
be added to the report to
helping
I would say improve the work itself
because I think that'll be a bit uh
presumptuous of us but to to make the
the work of Salk easier when dealing
with baber and the tougher
no
right but uh that report is just for
noting thank you thanks very much indeed
sorry
apologies
do we start jumping about a bit
um because we will now move on to item
13 which is the forthcoming decisions
list
do any members have any comments on the
forthcoming decisions list
we should have been circulated by email
on Friday
because of course it's updated every
week
that again is for noting so if any
nobody's got any comments on that we
will move on and having noted that
all happy
moving on then to uh
over your scrutiny Committee Action
tracker
um this is a wonderful sort of colored
colored chart any any comments on that
it's good to see that the
the red boxes have reduced in number
considerably
sorry the committee is still awake are
we
no comments at all on that one either
no
that again is for noting so we'll move
on from from the action tracker to this
is for baber district members only
um do beta members have any comment on
the over the scrutiny work plan
other than the fact that it's not
working you hard enough of course
they remember there's no comments on the
work plan
no
cancel grinding
thank you chair
um just having a quick look at the
Feathering meeting and the education
skills and employment
um
obviously
that doesn't come under the paper remit
so I just wondered what the thinking is
um
about us examining that as we we can
only influence we can't really do much
more make a you know recommendation but
you know this is not the better use of
our time to do something that we can
actually
um
influence more strongly or actually
change
I think uh you've got a valid point
there but at the same time we do have
quite an extensive ability to influence
as far as education and so forth is
concerned
by our our planning side and the
economic development side as well so I
think it's important that we do have a
look at it to see if there's any more we
can add to it to make it more valid
appreciate that it's a county council's
responsibility to to control that aspect
but that doesn't mean to say that we we
shouldn't have a look at it and be
prepared if necessary perhaps to
call the County Council into discuss it
with us
well no more strongly than anybody else
I'm just putting forward some
suggestions as to the the relevance Etc
I just wasn't sure if it was a produce
of our time
when you know there might be a more
specific
um
District related topic that um
we could examine
to do as well you know just just a
suggestion a valid point we'll get a
chance in January to revise it again if
necessary
Council Baron
thank you um yeah
on that point I think there is a
Point here
because if we focus on an area where we
have less influence and we have less uh
opportunities very nice to have a debate
about this and very interesting but it
means there's a cost that can be a cost
to that and that cost is less time to
focus on another area that is is
appearing on the same day as as time is
limited
um so I I do Wonder because I I I have
proposed one of those items in February
and I want to have sufficient time to
examine that in depth and I think there
is a risk that we won't do so if we
allow the agenda to become
um quite heavy with areas that are great
to discuss really interesting topics but
what can we really add to this
so yeah I agree
please maybe take a vote on it
but
um
yes yeah I mean can we make a
a decision whether we should go ahead
with us as a topic or not please
just just to clarify the um that was
mostly around
um skills and employment obviously it's
the owner to helm who is bringing that
report and it's the work that we're
doing with things like career curiosity
which I can't hardly say and um what
we're doing to promote employment
um in in you know our region so um there
is some influence that you can have so
it's not just about the education about
how we're informing
um that education around the things that
we're doing to promote apprenticeships
and other things
thank you
sorry
um so that's a favor report that we're
we're doing as a district
or a district level report it will be a
district report just for baber if it's
not on the mid-suffic work program
it's only with the soft work program so
it's across both districts what we are
doing around those items
may I ask whether it might be a good
idea to perhaps to having the topic in
them to make it more on the subject
that John's talking about rather than
the very Broad
topic that's on on the sheet please
if everyone thinks that's a good idea it
seems better to to narrow it down to
things something that we can
specifically
yeah you can reword your work program
and it is for the Committees you know
your your choice whether you take that
forward or just postpone it perhaps even
into the new year new Municipal year if
you want to concentrate on other matters
it is for you to decide but you can
reword that and it's for you to scope
and let officers know
um really what you want to have a look
at
but yeah it's all within your powers
without going into those little personal
details or anything else I think that at
the moment youngsters looking for
employment are all cut fast coming up
for
the needs of uh employment whether it be
qualifications or or whatever
there is a
a considerable need out there at the
moment for for guidance from
somebody
to help them achieve a meaningful
progress through life because they've
had a disruptive time over the last two
or three years with covid Etc and
doing gcses and a levels at the moment
for instance are under considerable
pressure
Council Brandon
can we
topic and what sort of wording would you
like to see that's more in line with the
work that the district's doing that John
has mentioned please
if everyone's in agreement
labor councilors
we're all happy with that Council Dawson
yes
so that that is he's noted except for
that uh that change in in wording of
that particular item thank you for
bringing it up Council ground
brings us on to Mid suffolks
work plan
and you're coming from mid-suffolks
councilors
perhaps on the issue of skills
attainment
Daniel we've got the general fund and
HRA fund which is often quite a major
topic does that need to be held in
general could that be put back um
okay there's no actual limits on as long
as we um we don't as long as we call a
meeting it doesn't have to you know
doesn't say I have to say the time scale
particularly however we do need to put a
line under that
pretty much as quickly as we can really
so we are aware of
um you know the the impact on the times
of what you've got and we know it's a
really packed schedule so
um but we have spoken to everybody and
they can make you know all their
Witnesses and the lead calling can make
that date so that hence why we've gone
forward we could postpone it if you so
wish but I would advise against it
because we really do need to hear that
that's gone on for a couple of months
now so we'll take you
it comes
yeah thank you it's um
it's something that Keith and I have
talked about as well um the you know the
workload on there but yeah yeah it is
something that we do have to address and
we can't we can't really do it any later
because it's just not fair on the people
involved in it and they they want to see
a um that scrutinized them as soon as
possible and it is like you say it's
it's two months down the line and we're
talking in the future as well so um but
yeah completely understand what you're
saying them councilor but um it
exactly how we discussed it and we said
yes it's got
to be so a bit Suffolk members you're
happy with your your work plan for
noting
yes
back a bit now to uh
item 11 on the agenda and the
public
term which includes the press to
consider whether pursuant to part one of
schedule 12a of the Local Government Act
1972
public should be excluded from the
meeting for the business specified Below
on the ground that if the public were
present during the item it is likely
that there would be the disclosure to
them of exempt information as indicated
against the item the author's report
proposed to be considered in part two of
the agenda is satisfied that when the
public interest is maintaining the
exemption outweighs the public interest
in disclosing the information
that's a mouthful can I have a proposal
please Council Caston thank you chairman
I think it is some really important that
the public are excluded from this
because
um information in this section of the
meeting could give potential um hackers
or you know um criminals a um insight
into how our cyber security Works which
would be very useful to them and um
obviously we don't really want that in
the public domain so um yeah I'm happy
to propose that this is done behind
closed doors
I now ask the lead officer to conduct
the electronic vote
that is eight votes for so that is
unanimous